una Plaza Father Conan moistest also my
blanquito hablo my poquito English
little English then go ten minutes
there's somebody definitely at home
right now be like Marge Marge you hit
that sa people in again what's he doing
when are they gonna build that wall what
ha 2017 s been good so excited making
good decisions this year the best
decision I've made so far as 2017 I'm
done with tall women get out of here
don't come up to me on the street but
like I'll wear flats for you no you had
your chance move on I'm five seven I'm
going five six and under from now on
that's yeah whoever said woo can get it
I'm going five six I got six more hours
in this town I'm going five six in under
and I know five six eliminates a lot of
the ladies so that's why I'm lowering
the minimum height you know what I mean
like the minimum used to be five feet
now I'll dip down or like 4 6 4 7
yeah like outdated for six curves long
as she has like regular people fingers
like I'll do like grown-up fingers you
know what I mean I'm talking Frank's not
Vienna's you guys get it
don't get weird cuz the thing is I used
to love dating tall women because then
you're my highly new day the tall woman
people look at you
there's a cool factor about it you know
it's not cool when the tall girl you're
dating picks you up in public like
physically lifts you never mess with
your street cred the girl I was seeing
she kept threatening to do it and I was
like no you can't but I think she
thought I meant like no you physically
can't like it was a challenge but we had
one too many drinks one night we're
outside of a bar we were huggin it was
adorable but she got ambitious you know
I mean that that whiskey courage came
out she hooked too tight like she hugged
and she like she like she she she lifted
it might be dangled and that was the end
of the relationship you can't be
confident after your feet dangle never
kick your feet on the fear as an adult
it's not a good look about pheromone
spray online last weekend segways there
for kids
I bought pheromone spray online last
weekend that's a real thing I own now if
you don't know what I mean pheromone if
you don't know what pheromones are
pheromones is that thing that a dude's
body is supposed to naturally produce to
attract women and I purchased it my body
wasn't making enough of the free stuff
it's supposed to on its own
I've been trying to find someone to
settle down so I've been thinking
outside the box I've been trying to find
someone because my ex is getting married
and that's that's a hell of a Facebook
invite we're still pretty good friends
it's a fun day it's a weird that we're
pretty good friends me and my ex play
this fun game to see who's having a
better life I rather that with the next
I recommend you try it and the reason I
know she's getting married was because
she called me to invite me to her
wedding yeah she's winning yeah but she
caught me she's like hey ro I love if
you came to the wedding and I was like I
don't know if I can make it
and she goes damn it ro it's my wedding
we've known each other for a long time
why just for one night can I have my
cake and eat it too I don't know maybe
because a cake has feelings you ever
think of that you psycho
maybe because meeting your husband isn't
the best way to keep the cake stable
like that's an option maybe the cake
might get drunk and try to sleep with
you on your wedding night
nobody likes a drunk cake wandering
around the wedding who may or may not be
doused in pheromone spray I don't think
she would have been the one though
because she came from a cat family you
know what I mean like when I met her she
was the lady who owned cats but her mom
was a cat lady so I saw the progression
you know what I saw and the thing is I
don't want women to get angry because I
don't mean any woman who owns a cat's a
cat lady it's not what I'm saying
there's a big difference and it has
nothing to do with how many cats you own
but it has everything to do with how you
name your cats because the lady who just
owns cats names are cat sprinkles it's
cute but a cat lady names our cat
Richard do you see how serious that
feels sprinkles is gonna have a life
just full of playing with yarn Richard a
lot of listening
you